hello everyone I just hit 10,000
subscribers and it's took my channel
some 18 days to grow from 5,000
subscribers to 10,000 subscribers so I
guess you guys do can enjoy the contest
I'm creating here and I decided still
were the one person with the official
feed a digital chess plug the BGC 2010
but we'll get back to that after I show
you the game so as you all know Michael
tall won a very strong tournament in
post or senior zonal in 1958 after that
he won the candidates tournament held in
Belgrade the Zagreb and bled in 1959 a
very strong tournament and he won it's a
one and a half point ahead of for Karis
so here he is this is a 1960 and he is
playing it in a beautiful tournament
hall in Moscow the Pushkin theatre in
front of him is sitting the world
champion Mikhail Botvinnik and this is
Game six of the Match tile actually won
the first game of the match they drew
dn't for next games and this is game six
and you might think that well since he's
one point in the lead in the world
championship match you know his he has
the black pieces he might play it cool
you know just to preserve his lead but
still has a different approach and
you'll see what I mean
so Botvinnik is white and he plays c4
the English opening now goes Knight to
f6
we have Knight to f3 g 6 g 3 Bishop to
g7 the King's Indian we have Bishop to G
2 castles d4v 6-9 to c3 Knight B to d7
about 20 castles and south way is a 5 we
have E for C 6 H 3 Queen to b6 and
bottleneck plays B 5c captures on d5 see
casters on d5 and top plays Knight to c5
and if you look at this position this is
somewhat of an equal position wise it
does have a bit more space since it is
for d5 but Estill always says if you
want to go for the win with the black
pieces you do have to give white some
sort of a positional advantage so what
sonic plays nice to e1 we have a big
study 7-9 to d3
captures on d3 botany captures on d3 and
we have recast the c8 rope to be one and
that's how plays Knight to h5 preparing
to push f5 we have to push it to e3
attacking the Queen Queen to b4 we have
a queen - E - R up the c4 and now rook
as the c1 and South Wales rotate to see
it just doubling up so what's an exploit
Kings - H - just improving the position
of its game getting some protection
village that h3 pawn and Tao pushes the
f5 we have it captures and s5 and now
Bishop captures an f5 and now that this
bishop is attacking the row can be won
so what's in place rook to a1 and this
is one of the most critical positions in
any World Championship game ever played
I mean I really want you to put yourself
in bosnia shoes here I mean you're one
hell of a guy I mean you've been world
champion for so long you you've defeated
champions like Lasker kappa blanka and
ejecting and your plank against this 23
year old guy they call him the magician
from riga and he plays a move like nice
to f4 and this is the this is one one
crazy position I mean what do you do
here let's see the knight is attacking
your queen he's also threatening to
capture your bishop obviously you can
capture the night but there are so many
complications here and what's only spent
a lot of time calculating this variation
and I mean one thing you should know
that there were a lot of people in the
in the playing hall and but there were
even more people outside the plane
called people who weren't able to buy
tickets for this match or were too late
because tickets were sold out I mean
immediately and they were watching this
game on large demonstration boards
outside of the pushing theater and well
they were they were cheering pretty hard
after after day so this Knights to a4
move so after a while was going to
decided to play G captures an F for
because I mean what you're going to do
the night the night is there to capture
it top lady captures on f4 and
this is the position that well a lot of
people resent Botvinnik for his next
move
but and why is that because if you ask
an engine an engine will say play a3 and
white has an advantage but botanique was
already low in time and he had to
calculate a lot of things he has to
calculate Bishop captures an a7 he got
to consider giving giving the piece back
you know just to improve but most when
he actually played Bishop to d2 and here
tau captures Queen captures and b2 so we
have rook a2 b1 attacking the Queen and
both Phoenix is not offering the rook
well the exchange actually just just you
know to get some counter play but Stahl
isn't interested in this and tunnel
wants to complicate even more and he
plays f3
so as usual Intel games it's blow by
blow by blow
and after f3 was Phoenix again low on
time decides to capture the Queen ropes
capture screen so tile captures a me too
and now both make plays rook to b3 we
have work to do for attacking the bishop
bishop to e1 and now Bishop to e5 check
the King goes to G 1 and now tau plays
Bishop to f4 and this is crushing
because well this rook has nowhere to go
if if you move the rook like rook day
ones and tells him to plays rook
captures on c3 row casters on c3 and
simply rook to d1 and this rockin a1 is
understandable you can't really capture
because black will get you guys get a
queen and well this will be over
so after Bishop f4 boss Phoenix plays
nice to e2 so talk a third row captures
on c1 Knight captures and d4 and row
casters anyone with check we have Bishop
to f1 and now Bishop to e4 we have
connect to e to Bishop to e5 f for
Bishop to f6
but when he captures the pawn on b7
Bishop captures on d5 rook to c7 Bishop
captures and a 2 row captures an a7 and
now Bishop to c4 we have rook th check
King to
seven root days injectors really nothing
to play here
King 2e6 wrote a three and now Kyle
Busch's d5 we have came to F to rook to
Bishop to age five checking the King
King to g2 King to d6 and now Knight to
g3 and how simply exchanges to Bishop
captures on g3 visual catches on c4 d
captures on c4 and King captures on g3
and as it usually is in health games
after the storm has calmed towel is left
playing the rooked ending being upon up
so we have king 35 rope to a7 c3 rope
the c7 King to d4 King to rook to d7
checking tothe king but in this position
was runic actually resigned without even
waiting for a reply from tau because
most when he has no problems assessing
disposition as as winning for black but
let's just see what would happen here we
have King III rookie center check King
City to rook d7 check King c1 and now
after King f2 route goes to e4 and now
South threatened to play rook to b4 and
you know making a safe safe line for the
king gun on this B line so the C pawn
can be pushed so white suit has to
defend this probably by rote to be seven
and now the table would simply gobble up
on all the pawns and well-being three
pawns up in rook sending this is
completely winning but like I said after
rook to d7
Botvinnik resigned without even waiting
for a response from tau so yeah a
beautiful game and it's amazing to me
that I mean this is game six and that
was one point in the lead and he plays a
move like Knight to f4 probably probably
definitely my favorite move ever played
in the World Championship match and yeah
tau
continued to win the match and he became
the world champion it's 23 result and
yeah the rest is history I hope you
enjoyed this game and now on to the rule
of the giveaway so the rules are pretty
simple in the comments of this video
just write anything about mikkel towel
while you like the guy while you dislike
the guy I mean maybe even something in
general you can even make it poetic
doesn't really mind and after you finish
your comments just press spacebar and
write hashtag towel I will put
everything in the description so you can
just read it and like I said the award
will be the official feed a digital
chess block so I mean it's my favorite
cloth to play blitz and official games
so I do think that it is a decent price
and yeah that's it I will post the
winner of this giveaway on my Facebook
page which is also in the description
below and I will mention who the winner
was in in a video I will choose the
winner but like I will write in the
description on 1st of August at 20:00
p.m. and yeah I think that's about it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I'll see you soon